Seven Thrones, seven wizards but long ago
we chose a champion
and we chose recklessly
he used his powerful revenge releasing
the seven deadly sins into the world
Uh, guys. There's six of us and there's
seven Thrones who's who's that for?
well whoever it is I'm going to love them
no matter what because they're an
automatic part of the family.
Primitive symbols.
You walking, talking monkeys. With your cave drawings.
You assume, there's only one way to gain magic...
No, No, No.
there are more ways than a Mind can imagine.
What in god's name?!
I named the gods. Doctor. Not the other way around.
Oh what fun we're going to have together.
The seven realms are about to be ours...
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie we
finally have an idea what's going on
with the Black Adam movie so we'll break
that down I know a lot of you are also
wondering because of the Joker movie if
it's going to be a little more hardcore
because we have the new idea of DC Black
Label and r-rated DC films we're doing a
movie ticket giveaway for Joker all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your best black atom theory on
the video most of you probably had a
chance to see the Shazam movie by now
there are a couple moments during the
movie where they very clearly talk about
the character then a couple that just
hint at him and then a couple of deleted
scenes that deal with them that they cut
out of the movie the rock himself is
actually a producer on the Shazam
franchise the reason why that is is
because originally they went to him and
cast him as black Adam before they cast
Zachary Levi as Shazam so they actually
started the franchise with the idea of
black Adam being the big character not
Shazam his production company was the
ones that started working on the movie
but when they were working on the script
they decided that there was way too much
backstory to set up for both black adam
inches and so that's when they separated
them into two completely different
movies and that's why you have a
blackout a movie now coming out after
this is a movie and why they cut a lot
of him out of the film that they changed
his backstory a little bit like that
first scene where the wizard is
explaining how they gave him his powers
five thousand years ago in conduct he
turned on them in revenge and released
the seven deadly sins on man that's a
big change to his comic book backstory
but it's all in service of making him
more of a villain when he debuts a
tragic villain that he slowly becomes
more of an antihero through the course
of his actions in the blackout of movie
which I'll explain in a second because
we finally found out what the story of
the Black Adam movie is going to be the
Black Adam deleted scene of them all
sitting on the Thrones and Mary Marvel
wondering who's supposed to sit on that
seventh throne and Darla talking about
bringing them into the family no matter
what quote-unquote no matter how
terrible they are how many people
they've killed is more about setting up
two shazam side of their eventual
crossover right now the black out a
movie is supposed to start shooting in
May they're still locking down their
cast but they pretty much have their
story and it is going to be a period
movie at least the version of the script
that they have most recently is a period
movie set in the 50s and 60s the reason
they're doing that is because they're
using the Justice Society sort of like
the older version of the Justice League
if you've read comics you kind of
understand the dynamic
between the Justice Society and the
Justice League but we haven't really
seen that in the DC Universe before so
when we hear that Hawkman Stargirl an
atom smasher were supposed to be in the
black atom movie it explains a little
bit more why you haven't seen those
heroes in present day because this is
sort of still keeping in the continuity
set up by the Justice League movie
Batman vs Superman without completely
rebooting everything I know there's a
lot of questions about the timeline now
because a lot of the movies are separate
you have the Joker movie which is DC
black label and not connected to the DC
Universe so some movies will be
connected to the larger DC Universe some
movies will not the black atom movie the
Shazam movies are connected to the DC
Universe the story the black atom movie
though is all about his quest to take
back what he lost his dead wife so
they're doing a version of his
comic-book backstory black out in the
Dark Age where he's being manipulated by
desaad so obviously the movies going to
change that plot a little bit just to
fit within their pre-existing continuity
but they're using it to explain why
black atom broke bad and set him up as
an antihero meaning that other people
like desaad are manipulating him into
breaking bad so that he doesn't come up
as quite an evil person but does a lot
of evil things until he learns that he's
been manipulated this whole time as for
the whole Joker DC black label r-rated
DC movie conversation of it all I'm
pretty sure that the black out of movies
going to wind up being pg-13 just so it can
appeal to a broader audience
pretty easy slam dunk for the rock who's
this huge international star to destroy
Shazam's box office but I just don't see
him doing a rated-r black atom film
because they do want to connect this to
the larger DC Universe so it's the films
that aren't connected they get to be as
dark twisted and hardcore as they want
to be that's one of the reasons why
Warner Brothers allowed todd phillips to
make an r-rated Joker film because it
wasn't connected to the other films the
Shazam post-credits scene is mostly
setting up the idea of the next - Shazam
movies so the whole idea is that mr.
mind is probably going to wind up being the
ultimate big bad he'll be a really big
problem during Shazam - I'll talk about
that in a second because they're
basically copying and pasting a lot of
comic book stories that are happening
right now and rebirth with the seven
realms of magic but also the idea that
mr. mind this small little alien insect
is
going to be the bigger villain for
Shazam then black Adam will be there's a
massive Easter egg when they're all
sitting on the thrones here and Darla is
talking about bringing this mystery
seventh person into the family Zachary
Levi revealed the whole plan for the
Shazam franchise including the Black
Adam movies is that Shazam too is meant
to go deeper on the Shazam Lee because
they've really only teased that at the
end of the film you didn't really get a
whole lot of time with the kids actually
using their powers you just got a little
taste for that go back one according to
sources close to the scene an armed man
has taken people hostage on the second
floor of that building the situation is
considered active police say the man is
wearing body armor and should be
considered extremely dangerous no and I
think we just found something you can
agree on we are following it closely
though we're going to go from the outside
now
Superman
so the sequel's going to deal with that
broaden the idea of the seven realms of
magic in the larger threat that they
have to deal with their responsibilities
as the new council of wizards if you're
not a big comic book reader think about
it like the Doctor Strange movie
what is his main job protecting the
earth from external threats from other
dimensions so the Shazam family does
kind of the same thing but they're meant
to be the guardians of all magic the
rock of eternity is the source of all
magic on planet earth in an hour
dimension the rock of eternity is a
focal point for several different
dimensions that sort of overlap in one
of those one of those realms of the
multiverse is the seven realms of magic
which is sort of a sub dimension that's
made up of magical creatures some of
them good some of them are really bad
but the whole idea of the Shazam sequel
is that it will create a whole lot of
chaos in the seven realms of magic that
will then lead to the entry point of
Black Adam like things go from bad to
worse when they eventually face off with
Black Adam then early prediction based
on Darla's language bringing this person
back into the family they'll be forced
to work with Black Adam to fix
quote-unquote magic so that everything
doesn't go to hell in the multiverse but
everybody let me know in the comments
what you think about the idea than doing
a Black Adam period film set during the
50s and 60s with the Justice Society the
proto version of the modern-day Justice
League for those of you wondering about
the other big movies like Justice League
2 the Green Lantern Corps movie they
just completed their contract with JJ
Abrams he's now exclusive to Warner
Brothers he'll be developing
quote-unquote other big projects for
them with huge IP I think that's code
for him working on a big DC movie he
actually turned down a half a billion
dollars from Apple to work with Warner
Brothers for half the price he only got
a two hundred fifty million dollar deal
from them because of all the extra IP
that Warner Brothers controls and that
includes all the DC movies early
prediction he'll probably go for a Green
Lantern Corps movie in 2022 or 2023
around the time Marvel is ramping up for
its Fantastic Four reboot but I do think
that if the Green Lantern Corps movie
goes well with him then they'll ask him
to do their Justice League sequel then
after that is probably when we would see
the next Man of Steel movie there was a
bunch of crisis on Infinite Earths news
I'll try to deal with that during my DC
TV videos that are coming up so if
any big questions about that just leave
them in the comments below
congratulations dank raccoon you're the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here for that mystery Batman teaser
and Batman movie news and click
here for that Avengers infinity Saga
trailer video and the Marvel phase 4
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight!